okay hello everyone welcome to another
welcome language design review part of
our incremental language development
series
uh
okay our first topic is soft Max
yeah we talked about this a couple weeks
ago
um you proposed having a standalone soft
Max function and then we had decided
that we didn't need it because we have
soft Max layer um and then yeah the
question is is it a useful thing I mean
a soft Max with a temperature it seems
like that's the thing people I mean
maybe it's not used outside of machine
learning
um
I'm not sure that was kind of my claim
is that I you know you can get it
through the layer pretty easily and I've
never seen it ever used outside of
machine learning and so you know getting
it through the layers I think how you'd
expect to get it
okay that's really true it's never used
outside of machine learning I mean you
know I had a very specific use case
because I was trying to describe things
admittedly related to machine learning
it's yeah right
all right
well um
drop it again
I might need to be reminded yet again
okay Geo nearest
yeah so we have Francisco and Jose here
um but this was a
discussion item we had on uh either core
design or ilde about
modifying the behavior of how geonerist
works with a Geo position with a list of
positions inside it
is that in nearly every place Geo
position of an array is interpreted as
the array of positions
except for the second argument of
journalist
which does some sort of grouping and we
want to change that to be consistent
with the rest
I'm at Geo position
of a list usually represents a
collection of points exactly
and so in Engineers there are two
possibilities are we referring to
their respective nearest positions to
respective capitals or to the capital
that is closer to the group of positions
well but is it it doesn't have to be a
one level list
um we could generalize it as far as we
want but the question is is it threading
currently not sure but we want to it to
threat
a model okay as opposed to saying
you've got a cluster of points you've
got another cluster of points what is
the closest approach between these
clusters of points
right now I'm confused here I'm very
confused if Geo nearest has an extended
region a country for example
mm-hmm
the I mean what does it mean which
country is nearest to which other
country
so here like look for example let's say
I say Geo nearest
of you know
countries
in Europe
and then I say North Pole
what am I going to get
so what did that just do
I mean that seemed to do something
reasonable it said which country has its
has a
point
that is closest to
the North Rule so so this is correct now
imagine that in the second argument you
had list geopositional poll comma the
opposition South Pole so now we expect
to get two different results right
because we have two
ah you didn't put a list did you
oh no I'm just trying to figure this out
what
that can't be right so that's something
yeah there must be some territory of the
Netherlands yeah right you didn't you
didn't use Geo variant of principle but
why did why did South Pole come back
with Antarctica
South Pole
uh that's about from alpha question that
I don't know
answer that that would be a good thing
to look at please looks like a bug to me
um well there are assumptions there
right so
you know probably as soon as South Paul
is a continent why on Earth would one
think of it as a continent
people I think in uh that's pretty
common when people say you know people
use traveling to Antarctica and
traveling to the South Pole is is pretty
interchangeable I think
um
okay all right so the question is if we
had two things here
yes if we have a list of two things
it'll do
it give us a list of two results exactly
that's what it does right now yes
okay
and and we still want to keep that
now the thing is that imagine that you
put your position at in front of that
list so that we get at your position
array in the second argument
So currently it will it's going to say
oh I have a single
thing and so it gets the country Which
is closest to both
closest to one of the points right it's
giving you the men of the mins exactly
yeah but these were extended objects
here
well your position would still
um
construct your positions
okay so let's for example let's say I
say China here for example
presumably the most useful thing though
would be the you know the the shortest
line right like the length the shortest
line is the distance
yes
the thing
right and given that Russia and China
share a border I mean that's a pretty
yeah right okay but but I mean so
let's say um uh
laughs
wow Russia wins them all yeah
Israel right you know the problem is
you're so far east that you know Russia
is the
right
okay that sounds plausible okay so now
what is the proposed change so yeah so
so
consider your first two inputs they are
different we are proposing that the
second one should give the output of the
first one
I'm not buying it why I mean what is the
geoposition of a list of things like a
composite geoposition thing no because
in most other places we consider that
the opposition array is equivalent to
the corresponding array of the
oppositions for example in your distance
if we have two the oppositional race it
will just thread as as if there were
lists
like geopolygon or something we have a
Geo Group and that's the at the very end
of of this we are proposing that
wrapping things into your group will
kind of group them together and consider
them as if they are one
so it would be Geo Group at geoposition
of the list is is a possible
representation of the of the group of
the points right whereas you want to
make pure position of the individual
points be like the list
exactly because that's the rule we
follow in other places it's very useful
specifically
um try your distance your distance of
and construct two random points of 10
for example
well currently it's just take the two
nearest input and change it to
geodesistance yes it's just it's just
random geoposition is a very easy way of
creating random
um
yes but here if I say Geo distance
right so you see you get our Matrix of
51 times 2 which is the list of 51
countries and the list of two but that's
not what I'm getting here right because
the trio nearest here
is returns a list because even they're
only confused this is this doesn't seem
right no no Gionee has to return a list
because in the case in which there are
two countries at exactly the same
distance I know right like nearest I
don't understand why this is making this
list of 51 however many countries in
Europe
for example nearest threads like this
yes nearest threats in the second in the
first argument but not in the second
argument sorry it threats in both
arguments except for the fact that with
a geoposition in the second argument it
doesn't it's an exception oh hold on
hold on hold on nearest doesn't do I
mean nearest of a bunch of you know if I
just say nearest of range of 10 right of
um
yeah to do nearest a range of 10 comma
range of five you'll get a thing that's
ten by five first of all I I get that
right and that's not analogous to this
because no no because you didn't give a
list of you gave a list of North Pole
comma South Pole instead of a single
thing right now but I'm complaining
about this down here I'm complaining
that geo-distance I would expect it to
give me the distance between
you know thinking of Europe as a blob
the distance between Europe and that I'm
not yet addressing whether this is
listed or not but let's say this says
comma comma North Pole I would expect it
to give me the distance of
sort of the closest distance of anything
in Europe to the North Pole
foreign
this is the ambiguity that I think is
being solved right is that if you have a
list it's unclear if like for example in
graphics we usually interpreting you
know a list is kind of like the union of
all these things right like if you want
to show two points you give a list of
here's a point I guess you can wrap up
the points but you know what I mean you
can give a list of the two things but
the point is here you need to know
whether you're talking about the
individual ones is a list or as a group
and that's what Geo Group resolves right
so I think the consistent thing is to do
what this does which is if it's a list
you thread and if you don't want to
thread use Geo Group okay remember
nearest never threads in its first
argument because it's asking which of
those first argument elements
is closest to the second argument
yes that's a particular thing of nearest
it trusts for example in the second
argument
what if what if the first argument of
nearest is a depth 2 list
then their points exactly like higher
Dimension points yeah
I see
so it hasn't had to address that issue
but Geo nearest would have to address
that issue because it doesn't you know
geo geo position is in three dimensions
it's in two intrinsic Dimensions as long
as it is a list of geopositions
everything is clear still
right so the proposal is
that so go ahead
just one thing so this question has
appeared because when you have many many
geopositions it's very useful to have a
single one with a packed already inside
and so that's what that's what we are
trying to do here is to
take advantage of that
you know I really hate that this
quantity Okay so
this is saying
that's the distance from the group to
the North Pole and the distance from the
group to the South Pole
can I find out what the
element of this that is closest to the
South Pole I mean I know it's the
Netherlands but can I find out where it
is
where is it
what is that you want the geoposition in
Europe that is closest to Antarctica yes
how do I get that
we don't have that functionality yet
but we do have a regions right that
that's cool it's confusingly region
nearest I think is what it's called
if I remember right oh no
yes
right region nearest doesn't tell you
which region is closest I guess you
could do that with normal nearest we
could have a distance function that that
operates on regions
um
right it tells you which point within a
region
hmm
so in a sense
wood region nearest itself
operate on
okay so which point within a region so
that's Geo Group of this
so would this just work
foreign
maybe okay yeah
needs a verb
yes
no that's correct
grammatically correct oh it's expected
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I didn't
read it properly
okay so what you guys are arguing
cool I mean
just tell me this is not an efficiency
hack story right
or is it an efficiency
it's more consistency thing in in nearly
all Geo functions at your position array
means the array of your positions except
for the second argument of journalist
did you want to have we haven't really
I'm not sure we've done exactly the
example right so the case is like if you
do geo nearest of you know
yes definitely
and it's obvious you claim I think so
yeah
so if you evaluate all these examples
there with Grenoble
Etc I think you'll see that there's a
lack of consistency at the end
of
nearest that one it should return
of journeyalist the one after the
proposed change is
the one returning only vaduz
I'm sorry that that's it
so more basically though I mean you can
see that the first the Junior's did you
know when you thread the geopositions it
gives a different answer right
isn't that that's kind of the main
problem case right yeah
you see that result
below it are different
exactly
does it flatten I mean if if I gave two
levels of lists here what would it do
and that's probably not understood I've
I think
right
yeah right
sure so it's listable in some sense I
think this is sort of outside like
that's not even related to this proposal
like that's just how junior is and
probably nearest mostly works right like
I think we're we're just talking about
what it means when you have a Geo
position we have a single geoposition
and the question is is it like the list
inside it or is it like a single object
exactly I think that and I think that
Geo Group is a good solution because
right if if we decided that so right if
we decide that it represents many
positions then you can use Geo Group to
disambiguate that no I actually need one
I mean one object but if we assume it
means one object there's no obvious way
other than calling thread and making
some gigantic expression within the
Brazilian geopositions you know right
wouldn't it be nice if the autocompleta
him to do something about Geo Group
yeah and I think I mean I think the most
convincing argument is that the is
comparing the penultimate and
anti-penultimate inputs on the screen
Auntie penultimate you mean this one
here correct
why does that one give one answer and
the one below it give two answers
okay
if you guys are all convinced I'm okay
with it but I I would like to just ask
what do we do to advertise Geo Group
which I have definitely forgotten about
multiple times
um well I guess we can add lots of
examples using it to geo-nirist now
certainly do that but I mean in I'm
asking here for example
um
can we
uh
let's see
um
I mean I'm just trying to think whether
there's any way to give some
autocomplete hint yeah
I can see that as being an interesting
pattern for other places too
I think we have the wrong set of people
so can somebody bring that to your
assistance meeting we could put a
dedicated use this message in that has
Geo Group explicitly in the user's
message and then it would show up in the
little left-hand down arrows you know
that's a good idea yeah yeah I agree
this isn't even show that this Show's
lat long oh no that's geoposition you
aren't your nearest
that's right
so you'd have
but you'd have lock and then you'd have
G I guess it would be the second one it
would be um
you know a Geo Group of Lock and then
you'd have all the others would have
lock lock spec or something yeah
okay but something like that can be done
okay
good I think we're turning to a
different topic then
so yeah
sorry
also the last handful of things from
some of the older design documents
specifically functions and features that
we either have in alpha or
um have been using and exposing as part
of Wolfram Alpha notebook Edition which
are not in the language some of these
have been moved to wfr and are worth
considering if we want to move them to
system and I'd love to get I mean I I
don't have okay and Roger isn't here I
assume yeah we don't have Roger and we
don't have Devendra so I think it might
be hard to talk about these I mean I
have some I have some comments as
somebody who works closely with the
calculus team but uh
um you know well I mean the question
okay
yeah we would like to support more kind
of um
sort of useful
[Music]
sort of more elementary math kinds of
things
I don't know whether these are they
what was it your comments to die well I
mean uh
personally I find it a little weird that
the
you know that stationary points I mean I
would argue that the stationary points
are you know the X values and this is
giving me a rule for the X values and
the Y value I agree I think it's right
yeah I don't think it's right
um
I mean I can see stationary points being
you know solving the derivative equals
zero problem right that would be useful
now you know it's kind of like Aug Max
versus
uh
this is the where is it zero
where is the derivative zero
and then what's the value of the
function at that point it's a different
issue because you might be interested in
what's the second derivative well you
might be interested in all kinds of
things
and to my mind it would seem more useful
to have something where it's like like
almost like root sum where you can do
something where you can say you know
summing over the oil doing something
over listening over the stationary
points what is the value of this
quantity is that crazy
I think we have the wrong people here
for this meeting
so I I agree with everything that has
been said in the reasonings presented
part of the reason that we wrote These
in the way that they are was because we
were thinking about Wayne and we wanted
to be able to have the full presentation
of information where for the more
elementary math consideration when you
are asked to solve a problem like find
the inflection points or the stationary
points or critical points Etc you want
all of the information and not just part
of it yeah I get it I get it solving a
different problem
right I mean it's makes perfect sense
for often Alpha notebook Edition yeah
um
and I think the only point I would add
to that is that
I think that should we make the change
should the should this become a system
function and the changes discussed be
implemented it should be clear in a
straightforward way how to get from one
to the other which obviously is doable
but yeah yeah yeah yeah we'll worry
about the bridge later first we figure
out what we want to where we want to go
the um
all right well I mean we can't really
discuss that without these other folk uh
and I don't know let's take a look at
some of these
hmm
is that a thing that we actually I mean
we certainly have that it's kind of an
interesting thing and I agree with you
it will be a nice thing to have here I
mean hopefully find sequence function
maybe so we're about to see some you
know new llm based versions of find
sequence function I don't know if it's
going to work but but um
it's something which is conceivable go
ahead what you're going to say well I
was going to ask uh so is this like you
know that's like pi squared over two I'm
not sure what the output yes yes yes
it's the analog of um uh what's the the
thing I mean we've got rationalize it
we've got some also
um
root approximant
what is that and why is that useful how
many times do I have to make this point
it's not useful
we have the wrong people here I guess
for this
I mean there's a ticket for it it'll
happen eventually
I hope it will happen soon it's really
bad it's really kind of useless what we
have here but but look I don't know
whether this is
um what do I say here I say permanent
polynomial or something what do I say
what what what are you wanting to do I
want the polynomial of which this is the
root
uh try first
that's a horrible thing but okay but
that's uh that thing
a root of that polynomial approximates
that number
so this is the the there are two things
we have rationalized we have root
approximant the fine number
representation I'm not sure it's the
right name would be the the thing that
will find the representation in terms of
presumably by default I mean if I type
that in you know if I do a wolf from
Alpha version of that
um
possible closed forms here we go
why does it have an underscore there why
does it not have a subscript
anybody know
on the website it surely has a subscript
should I try it
I would believe you my guess is there's
some issue or or an API issue
um
right
well somebody should investigate
um yeah but no nobody relevant to that
investigation I'm aware nobody's
relevant to that investigation is here
that's why oh interesting okay so it's
correct here so who can who from project
management is here and can report that
please Avery yep I can report it
huh I wonder what it's going to do here
I don't think it was very useful didn't
find any more representations but this
is what we're talking about but I mean
you know if we're going to make this
into a system function and I I do think
it will be nice and useful as a system
function we do need some ranking of
these I mean we have a default ranking
that was based on essentially how
commonly these things are talked about
in the world we should look these days
in common cruel I mean we have looked we
did it in archive years ago
um looking at how common each of these
um uh uh each of these constences to
decide how how much we should rank it
here
um
uh you know I realized I didn't look at
our comments on our chat about your
nearest
Seth is commenting there's a more basic
issue a journalist inside query
journalist works as a query is working
on for example a list of associations
but can give errors if the query is
working on a data set
who here knows about that
yes this should be generalized I think
we have received a report from him
pointing this out that generator should
work on data set it will be generalized
okay
and Sandra is coming to ingenious can't
really have the notation you have a
nearest asking for index distance
element Etc that's an interesting point
too
um so what's the comment that it kind of
already it should not well I don't know
I think it would be nice if it could
have but maybe it can't help for some
reason let me look
I think we have been exploring recently
to rule in the first argument means
something different
ah
oh does it
well oh no I guess I guess it wouldn't
be ambiguous if you have string names
exactly
we have been looking at that recently
Francisco right
yeah I mean that's exactly analogous to
nearest right nearest also exactly same
yeah yes so Arrow property sounds like
something we can do and that way
um
that looks that looks like a really
worthwhile thing to me
we are actually working on that I think
we have to recently discuss this fine
yeah
all right let's go back down here okay
so what I'm saying is for this number
representation thing
um I mean this was a this is a Michael
Trot production and Eric Western
production I think originally
here
right so I mean I would support
supporting that in the language however
I think we need to think a little bit
about
the sort of we probably need a second
argument which describes the class of
constants that we should be assuming so
to speak
am I talking to the wrong set of people
here
nobody knows if I'm saying it's one of
those if no one answer sentences yes
yeah I mean Michael was supposed to be
here and then he had to pull out for an
open AI discussion
um
yeah so we can we can try circling back
with him I've got I need to check in
with him and Eric about something later
today anyway so
okay
um
look I think
I mean this the fixing of this really
should go along with the fixing a find
Formula which
really should be modernized
I mean I think
and I don't know exactly where that's
going to fall because that's the thing
where you know that is a combination of
symbolic regression and modern machine
learning methods
um find formula as it is right now is
using a generation you know another
generation not a human generation a
technology generation ago of machine
learning methods
um maybe again this is there nobody here
who knows about it
Okay so
okay okay hint for the next one of these
meetings for goodness sake get the
people who actually know about these
things here or don't put them on the
agenda I mean again
for people
well am I rolling here
anybody here who can represent algebraic
code data that's an ad Peg production as
I recall
okay I think Michael's the missing piece
for all of this stuff
sorry to say well I mean algebraic codes
I'm not sure that's Michael particularly
that
I mean I think that packaging there's
several other people who
know about that stuff it's something
where
you know the question of
what we'd really like is something which
does a useful end-to-end thing of giving
you an error correcting code for a
particular situation
and I think that's going to require a
bit more understanding and heavy lifting
I mean algebraic code data I believe and
and that's
I don't even know what frequency
allocation data is that's FCC and and um
uh the um
uh what is it called International
telecommunications Union it oh okay that
that okay
non-mathematical frequency okay
yeah right right if I say 567 megahertz
it's going to tell me hopefully that
that is a UHF uh decimeter band
it's primary use in itu Region 2 is
broadcasting I wonder how I get the use
in other itu regions that seems like a
mistake here we should have a pull down
there for that
um again over if you can make that
suggestion that would be great yep got
it
if I say itu Region Three I'm going to
that understands that no
I should
oh my gosh it's talking about a place in
Nigeria
well well actually wait a minute what's
this radio topic
ugh
well that's very confused
that should work as well because that
should that should be a geographic
region
that makes sense I think we I think this
is stuff that was
um
let's see if I say
okay
as well as a music act apparently
okay all right anyway I I don't know
I mean that should certainly be a wfr
function
the frequency allocation information
um whether that's something that
deserves to be in the language I'm not
sure
okay um
and I mean it also is the case that
there's things like itu region whatever
should be Geographic
entities just like South bowl and North
Pole and so on are
not making sense
again we probably have the wrong people
here for that
uh
okay packing data
so we looked at this really briefly a
couple of months ago and said we should
have some of this
um the question is do we want to have a
dedicated packing data function that
then pulls out this information you know
but the visualization and
the
the data set that it provides are
potentially useful I mean the the pods
on Alpha have more info in there as well
I think there's a link at the bottom of
this section
um
yeah
exactly place
n shapes inside X shape I know yeah
I know it's pretty cool actually
I hope people know it's there one kind
of suspects they don't
um
if I say pack
10 squares in a disc does it work
oh yeah look at that
what about if I say n
pentagons
I don't think this is gonna work
nope
yeah I believe there's currently
a fixed set of polygons I'm sure there
are because I'm sure but but I'm sure
this is really related to
uh
that function whose name is just
horrible and I always forget it the
piano mover function um
region
what the heck is it called region
erosion Maybe
anybody know what I'm talking about
I can't think of the functioning of the
top of my head well here this is I think
it's region erosion okay
yeah or is it region dilation
I can never remember
yes I think it's region dilation so this
is the thing that
this essentially is convolving a disc
with a triangle I think
which turns out to be I think what you
need to know whether a piano of a
certain shape is going to fit around a
corner as you try to move it
would you understand what I'm saying
yeah these are really nice these are
really nice
um
I mean the generalized cases surely
you've got a list of shapes and you're
fitting them in a given shape how can
you do it
um
that was kind of my initial question is
you know is this kind of a
X data function where you know we have
certain I think it's a computation of
these and we know certain cases
yeah okay
because I can see this is relevant for
spheres inside spheres all kinds of
things like that over here so maybe
something to at least run by the regions
group as well and see I would think so I
think it's I mean I think the the
general problem is very hard but I think
it might very well be the case
I mean I also wonder this seems like a I
don't know how important this is but it
seems like a um uh
another one of those when in doubt use
machine learning type problems
because it's probably the case that from
knowing what the optimal configurations
are for lots of shapes you can guess
what it's going to be for some I mean
like I if I look at this thing here and
then I look at squares I don't know
maybe there'll be no relationship I
don't know let's see how many seconds
not much
I see this is packing it
in such a way if I say pack 11 squares
in a disk
oh boy
these are complicated optimization
problem
um
I mean because we have something a
little bit like this
in
uh you know sphere points is again
slightly like this
am I making sense I mean if I say and
that would be probably
I don't think we we give a lot of
services for this so to speak if you get
what I'm saying
it's just those are the raw points and
if I say you know sphere
I don't know
0.2 or something around that graphics 3D
I'm not it's not telling me what the um
okay and I presumably if I were to say
um
yeah I mean so that's making that's cool
actually oh look it's a look at that
it's an icosahedron what do you know or
is it no it's a dodicate or another
right and presumably if I say 21 points
but this is a very analogous thing in my
view
but again we're not providing a lot of I
mean we're just providing the raw data
of the points we're not helping you by
doing these visualizations particularly
but I think one of the points that is in
here that is not in here is this is
giving you the best center points
this
is also giving you the actual size of
the sub-regions
that you need
I think we have the wrong people here
I'm sorry I this doesn't seem like the
right right um
discussion I mean okay this was the list
of attendees that Michael suggested last
time well I mean I think we don't quite
have the right right thing here so um is
there anything else we can cover in this
meeting
um I have a list of a couple of wfr
functions we're going to look at next
time that I can send you
um at least what are they maybe I can
just find them
uh yeah the the
um
so
or I can go on yeah go ahead go ahead so
key sort like uh was actually something
that Bob submitted we have a handful of
Association functions I'll send along
but that one was at the top of the list
what is this
you have uh existing ordering and you
want to re-sort your data like that
ordering
I understand
so
in an ordinary list
I don't understand why you don't just
take this
in ordinary list what you would be doing
um and in this case I don't want to lose
any values like anything that's not in
the original in the
you know predefined ordering I just want
to put at the end in the original order
that it was
okay so that's the difference so I mean
otherwise yeah
you know I would just do you know the
permutation here
so okay so the issue here is
that which is not mentioned
should be put where at the end yes
maintaining the original order
right it's a sorting function it's not a
taking it's not a
you know
part function
so you don't want to lose things you
don't want to
add
things you just want to reorder it I
don't understand why it doesn't default
some kind of thing in the key take
what it says because key take
usually would have
take these right but but the question is
what happens if there's a default
in other words if you if you put all
into the list of or something that isn't
quite the right way to do it
in other words if you had something here
I mean I also have a sort like that
isn't about Keys that's basically the
same thing for
the values or any list
so in other words it's putting the
values that you call out
first
and then leaving the rest separated
right
and why isn't that
let me think I mean if you just broke
the list into two pieces the one that
has
the I mean I think that's what it's
doing yeah
this isn't plotting my book particularly
it doesn't seem like I mean it seems
like it would take me longer to figure
out what an earth dysfunction will be
called
then um
uh
this is a concept that applies to all
certain functions in effect this is
providing an ordering function by saying
I prefer this objects to the other ones
right
uh
right it's just a convenience for
defining an ordering function based on
data
well maybe we should have it be one of
these uh sort of
wrappers that defines an ordering
function
I think we should probably declare
uh
a little bit of defeat on this meeting I
think we don't quite have the right
right stuff set up for this
um
and uh
yeah okay anything else you think we
should cover right now
no I think we can okay all right good
stuff see you guys soon
bye for now